the last photo I took was me dress up as
a squirrel with a nut hanging in my
mouth and I will not explain this I took
a photo of um french fries and fried
pickles
cuz I'm pumped on my lifestyle I was
traveling in France because I'm very
fancy ooh and I kept asking for the
scallops what he brought me was a big
big piece of fried meat so I think
that's like a veal scaloppini thing but
it was like the size of my torso and I
did not eat it I don't want to eat a
piece of meat the size of my torso but I
documented it different for posterity I
have another photo of me in a different
squirrel costume I have different
versions of me as a squirrel this is the
last thing on my phone do I have a
stigmata which was in my google search I
think I just pinched myself but you
never know how to hide a body that's in
there Bill Pullman sex scene and the
first thing that shows up is the last
seduction which I haven't seen
I looked up driftwood goat cheese and I
think you can't buy it in the US what's
driftwood goat cheese just a good goat
cheese I guess yes my last text message
is a group text from everyone from when
we were back in Hawaii and this is
Aubrey Plaza don't don't show that okay
I won't know you can you get it didn't
ya
mommy needs her birthday medal my
birthday drunk in a hotel room at 5:00
in the morning
now I've got I've got 1 1 7 a.m. alarm
my gosh I'm a boring loser I've like 65
really I mean no that's an exaggeration
but I have a lot whoa
starting at 3:45 going all the way to
7:50 p.m. hey I'll be sleeping you know
you can just change ya know you don't
like had a new no I know
okay the one with the heart eyes oh
that's cute the eye Rollie guy and then
the rainbow so kind of sending mixed
messages I guess and the German flag
super um wait what am i doing
canard you looking up emojis just click
on someone and then you you click on the
thing yeah is that Amelia west of us
yeah let's not go there okay okay yours
is the hand clap followed by the mad
sign okay and the finger yeah the black
metal fibers Oh mushroom and fried egg
I'm cold